is this a true story that you were cast
in Django Unchained and you left because
it was out of control or is that just
[__] that's [__] it is I was
casting it I loved him all right yeah I
love him I loved him and I went in and I
read with Jamie Foxx we did readings and
stuff and I was so pumped to do it right
and what happened was they had problems
on Django they kept pushing they kept
pushing my part they kept pushing my
part they pushed it for like months and
then I got another job as soon as I got
that job we're ready for you Queen is
ready because I'm like quite like uh I
said I have to not do it he did though
did you talk to him about it he never I
don't think he ever spoke to me again